have you received any push back from
longtime kill Tony fans who are a little
angry at you for potentially knocking
off a future Hall of Fame regular out of
the show completely first of all there's
Tony already said one of us might be
temporarily banned from the show so like
we don't know the consequences the
consequences is I will lose my golden
ticket and I have the feeling that will
be not temporary if I lose which is
likely to happen if H loses he'll get to
do the things for a bit and I'm sure at
some point he'll come back you know what
I mean there's he's a he's a he is a Kil
Tony Hall of Famer for a good reason
he's earned that right to be named that
if if that even existed but you know
like he's earned like the love of the
fans and he's collected that over you
know months and months and months and
months and months of working hard for
that show